[Music]
hi i'm priyanka vergaria staff developer
advocate at google cloud and in this
video i will share my top 10 tips to get
your first cloud job in india are you
ready
let's go
number one
understand cloud computing how is it
different what is the opportunity that
it presents big players in the market
understand a high level market
perspective in terms of jobs cloud
specific roles the kind of expertise and
the experience that's needed for them
number two opportunities in cloud are
across industries and various expertise
areas infrastructure networking
application development security
operations automation and more
you can be a professional with years of
experience in any of these areas and
continue to work in these areas in the
cloud number three the importance of
community join a local community where
peers discuss topics and areas that
they're working on this is a great way
to understand what others are doing in
this field and the kind of opportunities
that exist
be a giver to the community join it talk
at the events help coordinate events
review talks conduct workshops every
event is a platform to learn and gain
something that adds to your cloud skills
you're likely to hear about job
opportunities from this group we just
launched a community program for google
cloud developers and technical
practitioners called the innovators
program
joining gets you unique access to live
and interactive events technical
discussions and much more to come
check out the link to join
number four and this is a really simple
one communication skills and technical
skills are a winning combination number
five be authentic cloud is a vast area
and a really fast moving one identify an
area or two within a cloud provider that
interests you bring in your prior
experience and go deep it's okay to say
that you're still learning most
important is the curiosity to learn
every day
number six
augment your current skills bring your
existing knowledge around application
development and think of various factors
that are unique to cloud development
like scale resilience high availability
pay-per-use governance operations
security and more
number seven
if new to cloud start with a foundation
course that gives a broad overview of
the cloud provider and its services for
example google cloud fundamentals
number eight targeting a certification
bring focus and discipline to achieving
it put a date to it google cloud india
recently had a road to certification
program form a study group with
colleagues
number nine
build your portfolio focus on
implementing deploying a solution to the
cloud
document your process what you learned
what you could have done differently
publish these learnings let these be the
start of your artifact that you can show
to prospective employers around what
you've been doing
focus on building more artifacts talks
that you can give on the topic blog
posts github projects and more
these should form a portfolio that you
highlight when you're going for a job
number 10 a referral works best reach
out into your community and your network
they know your work share your latest
learnings and artifacts with them see if
they can put in a referral those were my
top 10 tips to get your first cloud job
in india
now if you stuck around this far with me
then that means that you're motivated so
here are my three more practical tips
that can help you in your cloud job
search in india india's b2c sas market
with investors funding has never been
stronger than before
all of them have the cloud powering it
behind the scenes these companies should
be on your list to check out relevant
cloud job postings
traditional it service companies are all
investing in the cloud services division
and forming a cloud center of excellence
so plenty of opportunities opening up in
these it service companies with focus
solely on cloud
the traditional enterprises like the
banks the automotive companies telecom
have taken giant steps in recent years
these firms are investing big in cloud
creating significant opportunities for
job seekers overall if there was ever a
better time to be a cloud developer
it is now
go out there and apply i wish you the
best in your journey and don't forget to
share what worked for you in the
comments below
[Music]
you